hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
we have a bit of an exclusive something
that you haven't seen anywhere else on
the internet and this is the first place
you're getting to see it with me here so
this
is a live case for nexus so if you have
a nexus 6p or a nexus 5x then this is
the case that you can get made
for your phone now it's a little bit of
an interesting process google has
decided to share it with me so i'm going
to turn around and share that right back
with you let's go and take a look at a
highlight so here's how it works you
might remember this image i've had it as
a wallpaper in like half my videos this
is a facet by justin mallard shout out
to justin he's done a ton of awesome art
like this i'll link his stuff right
below that like button so to make the
case you upload your image to google's
live case design studio it's a web app
just for this so you can upload and then
drag and position the picture how you
like on the case center it up fill the
area do what you got to do and there it
is and if it's a super simple image you
can even further customize it with a
couple built-in effects for adding color
or like a dual tone look or stripes or
patterns or whatever you want now the
facet here is already pretty complex so
i'm just going to appreciate it in all
its original glory boom that's it you
can choose between matte and glossy and
you're done and that is what your case
will look like according to the site for
when you should get it and as you can
see in real life it's pretty much on
point with how it looks on the site it's
a direct conversion between the image
you uploaded whether it's one that you
took on your phone or maybe photography
or art is your hobby whatever you want
it's a direct conversion of that and
it's a quality print too i mean this
happens to be a 4k image but most photos
you take are larger than that and just
like that you have a one-to-one limited
edition nexus case and even if you don't
have a photo you want to use they'll
also let you use a google maps location
so let's say there's a city or a spot on
the map that's special to you maybe a
dope bridge or your favorite park or the
location of a new studio whatever it
might be on google maps you can position
it exactly how you want on the case and
get it made like that there's also some
customization of the style of the map so
you can be sure that your spot is truly
one of a kind so live cases is pretty
unique and it's actually pretty decent
case as far as they go i mean obviously
i'm not a huge case person but these are
designed specifically by google for
these phones so the port cutouts and
button cutouts and the fingerprint
reader are all pretty much precise
they're on point and there's also a bit
of protection which is the advantage of
a case so the lip on the front extends
just a tiny bit past the glass so if
your phone goes face down on a surface
you don't risk any scratching now here's
a cherry on top inside every live case
there's an nfc tagged button when you
install the case for the first time and
press the button you get linked to the
play store to download the live cases
app that's a new app and then the app
will let you set the image you
originally uploaded as your wallpaper
for a little dual color action front and
back so after you've set that the live
cases app will let you set the button as
a shortcut to something else so to
toggle the flashlight open the camera
toggle wi-fi or even open any app you
want on your phone so for the sake of an
example let's say i calculate a lot of
things i need the calculator app a lot
so i'll set the case button to open the
calculator app now anytime i want
wherever i am press and hold that button
for a second and boom calculator so i
think this is pretty cool i have a
couple other versions here which you can
see this image is one of the best
smartphone photos i've ever taken in the
fog with some triangles for effect
this one is just the mkbhd logo front
and center no customization and this one
is the golden gate bridge
can you see it it's an overhead google
maps to you see now you see it can
pretty much guarantee no one else has a
case like that so there you have it
that's a pretty quick and simple way to
literally customize your phone in a way
that nobody else can and it just kind of
gets me thinking more about like
customizing your devices and electronics
i did a dope tech episode all about
custom tech where you can skin your
phone you can get it custom painted this
is just another thing to add to that
list so i'll leave that link below if
you want to check that out as well
either way that's pretty much it thank
you for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace